hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I'm restoring one of
the coolest axes I've ever restored want
a sneak peak yeah
[Music]
I was working in my driveway postman
pulls up and drops off this lovely
package all the way from Bulgaria and my
Cyrillic snot very good but if I'm not
mistaken that says Lord God's key pushy
yad which probably means Bulgarian post
office or something like that well guys
let's see what's inside this thing
oh-ho
the thing smells like cigars and
unfiltered tobacco this sees some old
Bulgarian guy sitting smoking in his
workshop well this is a bearded hatchet
or a goose wing hatchet it's got an
awesome shape to the blade it's got a
little bit of an offset like a hewing
axe yeah check it out it's really hard
to see but it looks like somebody
crudely etched their initials in the
blade in Cyrillic it's all dented in
right here looks like someone's been
beating on the back of it with a hammer
it's asymmetrical it's you know kind of
flat on this side and it's got this step
right there and the handle is not
exactly in very deeply a little bit of
pitting from rust but guys this is our
cool little hatchet and frankly I love
how beat-up it is I'm not sure what the
handles made out of but it looks like
some piece of scrap wood that somebody
just whittled down to a handle it's
probably just been used as a splitting
maul just put it down
whack on the end and that's why they
never bothered to put a wedge in there
well guys this is gonna be a pretty cool
little project so I gotta put some
thought into what I want to do with this
and I want to do something pretty
special with this I think well first
things first I'm gonna try to get this
dent out of the back of the axe head and
for that I'm gonna he
of the forge
[Music]
yo
[Music]
putting an axe head like this in the
fire is a great way to take the rust off
however there's a big downside when an
axe maker or a blacksmith creates this
steel he heat treats it he heats it up
to a very specific temperature he cools
it down in a very specific way and he
may even do what's called tempering
which is a process of lessening the
hardness of the steel to avoid
brittleness now each type of steel and
there's many many different types of
steel is heated and cooled and tempered
in a different way and I have no clue
what type of steel this is and depending
on what type of steel is I may have
messed it up a whole bunch or maybe I
didn't I it's really hard to tell so one
of the things I'm gonna do to try to
gauge the condition of this steel is I'm
gonna test it with the file I'm gonna
take my file I'm gonna rub it along the
edge and see how much material it takes
off does it skate across the edge of the
blade or does it dig in and take pieces
off then I'm gonna go ahead and heat
treat this by heating it up and dipping
it in some peanut oil and I'm gonna test
it again with the file to try to gauge
the condition if it comes off too hard I
then might do a tempering process so
we're gonna see what happens well even
after being through the Forge a couple
times this steel is maintaining its
hardness pretty well it is coming off
with the file but we're gonna go ahead
and work the edge with the belt grinder
get it all shaped up the way we want and
then I'm gonna heat treat the blade when
you use fire to remove rust from steel
you get this red oxidization that pops
up all over the steel it's kind of
cool-looking actually
[Music]
look at that big old crack right there
in the blade looks like it's a
delamination so the crack goes this way
instead of down so odds are it won't
cause us any trouble seen a lot of
blades with cracks in them never had one
break into yet this could be the first
but I'm not terribly worried about this
thing
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
when I tested the blade after quenching
it it really hadn't changed its hardness
which led me to believe that this was
probably mild steel which isn't affected
or hardened by quenching but that's
pretty common with these old European
axes all right dad's looking pretty good
I'm just gonna go and knock off this
scale with Swire brush here see what
happens all right that's not looking too
bad at all now let's get working on the
handle I've got here a piece of exotic
hardwood called Cadillac it's one of the
hardest hardwoods in the world I think
it's like the thirteenth hardest in the
world or something like that it's a dark
beautiful beautiful wood this piece is
meant for turning and it's covered in
paraffin but this thing is gonna look
gorgeous when you get it all shaved up
[Music]
fitting the ax handle to the eye is the
most difficult part of this whole
process these hand forged axes are not
symmetrical they're not a consistent
shape so you just got to kind of carve
the the ax handle as best you can and
really slowly and carefully through
trial and error try to get the tightest
bit possible you slip it on as best you
can
jam it on until it's stick and then pull
it off and see where the marks are at
and that'll tell you where you need to
take off material after you've hit the
head on you'll get these little marks
where it's tightening up and that's
where you need to remove material so
right there right down here right down
here right down here well there we go
that's that's looking pretty good
you like it you think it looks good I
like what I've got so far but I need to
stop and take a little break for dinner
so we're gonna go do that and I'll pick
this up in a little bit well it's
another beautiful day and we are working
on this bearded axe project again I'm
gonna start shaping the handle getting
all smooth and nice for those of you who
haven't been following our channel you
might be noticing my shiny new silver
play button belt buckle celebrating
100,000 subscribers so you guys want to
check that video out click the link all
right let's get started on this handle
[Music]
well that's not too bad looking nice
that is a pretty piece of wood right
there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right why did something cool with
this sheath so I've got this whetstone
here and I want to make a little pouch
on the side of the sheath for the
whetstone so that you can take it out
sharpen your blade up put it back in and
to do that I've got this wet piece of
tool leather and I'm going to wet form
this around the whetstone to make the
pouch I can't make it too snug otherwise
I'll never be able to get the whetstone
out I am going to make a little spacer
here there's a piece of cardboard around
the top all right I got the little
pocket formed I just need to let it dry
and then we'll keep going on the sheath
well it's another beautiful day I'm home
from work and we're gonna finish this
sheet all right let's check it out yeah
that looks good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright that cheese looks pretty good
but let's put a finer edge on our racks
generally just get it razor sharp
not the sharpest I've ever gotten ax but
it'll do look at well guys I think that
turned out beautifully look at that that
is good-looking yeah I really like how
this turned out
now technically speaking this is a huge
ax it's flat on one side and slightly
offset and the purpose of that is so
that you can go and shave down the side
of a log and make it nice and flat but I
think whoever been using this lately
been using it to split wood because
they've been beaten so much on the back
they were like bam bam bam and using it
to split logs which this will do as well
it's just a beautiful fun axe it still
works good and it's cool a lot of you
guys have been asking me to do an axe
giveaway and I'm gonna do just that I'm
giving away this X however I'm not gonna
do it quite the way you wanted because
I'm giving you the wood of my brother my
my brother's big outdoorsmen lives up in
Alaska with the most my family and he I
know has been coveting some of these
axes I've been restoring so I wanted to
do something nice for him and wanted to
make one for him so I'm gonna go slap
this bad boy in the mail and I'm gonna
go send it to my sister-in-law and to
have her go surprise him with it
thank you look this is awesome
well thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos like this I have an entire
playlist of axe restoration and tool
restoration videos and a lot more videos
coming up so make sure to hit that
subscribe button and if you like these
types of videos make sure you click like
so that I can know that that's what you
want and we can do more in the future
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video